[Music]
you
hello and welcome to our monday night
show yeah hello and okay hello to all of
you in the chat you are already some
activity down so let's get going i'm
happy to play a couple of games i've
been on duty all day teaching but
haven't played a single game let's see
if I can get some games going we have a
couple of childhood players on so should
be possible any fan favorites on that
should be checked we are a couple of
what about Yardbird no don't see a bird
only gas is not on yeah my own getting
started also has suffered a little bit m
getjar something like that so we get a 0
check the fence yeah this this line is
not particularly great for black but it
is it is tricky and see what he what he
plays with Bishop g4 whoa what I you
friggin serious so if i take on d5 is
going to play a form
okay let's keep it simple or is he
taking with a pawn even that would be
quite crazy but maybe
so he took on you for whoa okay so I'll
take f6 I guess so what is he doing now
take you on f3 maybe this actually
threatens f2 yeah I can play the
caro-kann it's just that I usually
forget about it it's not that I'm
totally against the idea it's just that
when it comes to me having black and
they play efore I just play my normal
stuff okay so i'm just a pawn up here
for nothing at least that's my take on
it no I'm a bona
I don't see any compensation this one
okay 22 I guess I'm bishop age six is
certainly useful to have so is he going
to Castle long in this position maybe
but okay probably he will do that just
to irritate me if you cancel short after
Bishop age 6 s position just is worse
form for without any particular chance
of of counter plane okay this is what he
does so let's go Bishop h6 I don't think
he wants to get my queen to age 64 the
polenta tube nope so it takes it and
yeah let's see
oh d 5 on a couple of good continuation
cm can also double on the FR night
double on the FM maybe a gem it's not
quite Clem yeah how can you help
teammates and club members to improve
well this is a general question how to
improve a chess I mean when it comes to
spend a certain amount of time it's a
good idea it was written through fusion
says do some tactics yeah constant
tactical training is a good way to use
the time ok well here I can I wonder do
I really want to take them Queen g5 is
also move threatening and threatening to
take on f7 I Scott f6 though okay I'm
just going to take the cubed keep it
simple style and now maybe just c3 on
yeah I just go see 325 is a dangerous
move yeah Queen g5 and 94 those those
look very dangerous so I'm going with
this don't think much more maybe I
should have but this is definitely
dangerous here yeah look at seven
basically winds right check check black
resins jam your tactics you can do on
your own tactics trainers this kind of
thing so let's get a new game going this
whole line by the way is quite
questionable what white has to play a
form anything else doesn't really cut it
okay it does admit it's a question how
much time somebody has pinata asks if I
have polish roots um yeah this is a
matter of definition certainly my let's
be correct there what is the correct
word of that like the father of my my
grandpa yeah they they come from what is
so nowadays quarter I know what it's
called nowadays it's nowadays in Poland
it's it was part of the gain the start
most eastern part of germany back then
which is nowadays nowadays year since
the Second World War is of course polish
so it's not like um i was born in poland
on my parents or something but back then
those areas Verger
so we have the Berlin here by clearly on
which is quite surprising I think I go
buddy three I goes d 6 ok so we just
play normal looking oops rudo PES yeah
I've played a lot of my repertoire
actually I've played the banco a lot of
the English yeah I use the lines myself
yeah I wonder what is up to maybe a five
like night age 7 + f5 that's possible
[Music]
yeah sure it's a it's a typical Eastern
European name
[Music]
but in my family um nobody speaks a
Polish for example they just at the time
the beginning of the 19th century they
migrated from that area of Europe to
where I live now so he's we can see
five-year a little bit surprisingly and
I was i'm not sure if I'd that helped to
put it on c5 but it's a it's quick here
[Music]
okay interesting where is he going with
this Knight to c4 maybe night b7 I don't
know let's see
yeah i'm working on e4 repertoires yes
yeah king and tonight we're this King is
a draw with good defense so we get to
trade this one but now I should be able
to i took with the king yeah ok 22 is a
good move anyway so let's see here he
will probably put the Queen to e7 can I
do something about it I can maybe do
this here we go greenie 7 and no he's
not going there but this is not so great
right Queenie 7 Bishop f4 this is not
very nice Bishop d7 I think I can even
take no we cannot take but close that's
not fun
[Music]
just doubling doesn't do the trick I
think
I just wonder I mean let's let's do this
it's a little bit I would like I would
have liked to check this a little bit
more thorough labored I think it's still
interesting so let's do it Queenie 6
Quincy five he has to return the
exchange I thought hey is a tricky
player the sky okay unfortunate so I
cannot even take only five now this
doesn't net-net anything that was really
useless am I just had a great position
and then i miss misjudged this thing
[Music]
that position really sucked look like
just doubling was good i didn't see what
he ate I kind of had to fear that
something was wrong but I didn't quite
didn't quite sense what it was
hmm let's see is that such an easy win
maybe it is
Knight b6 he wants to play okay then
night f four counts
kind morning pretty awful is that he has
such a crab rating he usually is much
stronger than this rating so this is an
extremely costly game his jewel is
sitting on 2405 2500 it's a bit weird so
yeah still continuing he have it yeah I
just give him gifted him in exchange
yeah the won't work that I'm doing is
I'm just looking at the Sicilian other
things are secondary one is taking a
while
he didn't find anything here so I make
him make him look again so what's going
on here and not much try to go to e3
Queen a six is probably good night so i
can check hmm Wow check check yeah I
lose on Tom jackie has really misplayed
that completely but I'm Jay able to use
it check I'm just chatting on time okay
white forfeits on time now that was
trouble there was trouble just an i
could not give up the exchange that was
a bad idea i should just play normal
moves and be fine
so let's get a new game oops should
switch that off it's a bit of an
annoyance hear this sound okay damn I
should not take on the seven down gain
started over the group d 8 so give enter
whisk inventor no further information I
don't those profiles sometimes so let's
see what happens yeah this is an
interesting line that i recently picked
up now this early age porn thrust is
quite dangerous for white it's something
that I've found while compiling my
English opening repertoire wow that's a
bad move t5 well okay um yeah Bishop
takes Knight X they're both good I think
Bishop takes
yeah is closed down his diagonal him
giving me huge edge on the kingside what
that is a weird way of playing yeah so
how do I kill this off I think maybe a
queen to g6 could be an idea IOC playing
for long castles in this position if he
does I'm going to let's just fire him
you're not going to Castle long now that
much I know I would idea 90 for him ok
that would that won't work
[Music]
yeah so why wait is White's King going
to go at the end not easy at all rook g1
I can take age three yeah so before i'm
not sure about that is that grade but
let's let's do this open this up
that's not not exactly comfortable a
white if you move the rock now I have
Bishop f3 and Knight takes Queen takes
looks dangerous well it's going to be
very dangerous
let's threaten 9065 yeah this pin is not
easy for him and the King cannot move
it's not quite sure how he's going to
handle the situation
that looks pretty terrible I don't
really see how he coordinates you can
barely move anything I just wonder if
9065 how good that actually is but it is
probably quite good because I'm
threatening night before and then
invasion on d3 after he took with the
bishop the light squares arm yeah that's
an important important thing that this
mentioned in the chat openings that are
named after animals are usually bad this
is the rule of thumb that is working
quite well so if you come across animal
named openings it doesn't really hurt to
just don't play them yeah so I'm going
to take him idea being night before
Muslim
yeah I can even take it mmm Bishop you
for night f4 is also interesting that
threatens the night g to check made
shouldn't be that bad let's do it check
I'll take the Queen white forfeits due
to disconnection kind of fits and anyway
he forfeited due to this connection and
now this is really that's not a good
line anyway for what I think after you
played d5 that gets that gets tricky
this looks extremely aggressive and it's
dangerous it's definitely dangerous are
they had shock yeah that's true the
hedgehog is quite good and the black
line the black line is ok actually start
if you play it somewhat conservatively
there are some some ways of playing it
that is just not going to work well but
if you don't do anything fancy it's ok
just like the food or hand and variation
isn't so bad yeah dragon counts i think
but it's not as bad as the typical
animal opening yeah but that's no good
paranoid okay sure yeah that i played
this too quickly i played this too
quickly and now he's ok just age 5 or
whatever man that that's annoying him
that he gets away with this this black
line can't hit lee terrible what he
played
on d4 bit should be six is just
completely terrible i played 95 too
quickly ya hear this this is just an
absolutely terrible position for black
even just a three is good and then they
take on the King side and I would miss
time 95 here unfortunately yeah now
Black is fine the ending is fine
yeah he's got a good ending here that's
very typical that the endings are good
I've got that rook FC eight cleared to
have eight square that's really annoying
I mean this is an unplayable line it's
really unplayable for black this kind of
stuff I'm not exaggerating here I
checked this for my for my repertoire
suggestion and it's just completely bad
for black I played just 95 far too
quickly
[Music]
yeah funny animal opening name is the
vulture that was developed in germany
bashed a hog buca the snake benoni is
also pretty bad
I did not take with the rook they're not
quite clear why home
this position is just uncomfortable I
cannot easily take here probably should
though I don't really see anything but
she'll
[Music]
gianluca have one now that's not the
kind of move you want to play it I
probably have to
I still cannot get over that opening
thing really hate to yeah I let people
get away with bad openings okay this is
still not totally easy from my king is
quite active and I can run the beep on
up the board okay the question is now I
[Music]
think I'll put this on if you take see I
checked and take age seven the G porn is
rather dangerous the same that this end
cap isn't cleared all this isn't clear
at all if you cannot take on edge for
it's not quite clear what is movers
I should have thought about this I
really should have came and so check the
econ
cannot push the beep on then let's go
behind it check
[Music]
yeah the bee pollen is rather quick
check then all check flies time warning
to the deep on so I can promote now I'd
see here rook e8 after that I cannot
move my king / rook b1f for King z5s
weekend I don't know can I draw that
book the 814 25 a-3 king 0f to that's
too late I have to do this this probably
won't be enough can you talking you five
is a draw and then you can go King you
too unbelievable by one temple okay
quite resigned now next time you're
going to get punished for that opening
buddy Oh game game started Oh GM your
shake so let's get going here plays a
song in with black and do have any
hobbies besides chess um yeah not really
at the moment when I was working back
then in the office I had chest as my my
OB em and then invested lots of time
invest the time in the channel and so on
and now I really spent lots of time on
working yeah especially teaching and I
didn't really come to a point where have
time for the for hobbies yeah I'm
constantly doing stuff related to chess
which is not something that I want to
keep on doing I need to do some other
things but currently nothing so very
quick play here by mr. Yosh chick it's
my a pawn that week seems he feels
mighty porn is very by a porn is
extremely weak so let's set see what is
what is doing here going before here or
i would like to play a 5m so what is
your point I have Bishop d8 I mean if I
really really want to cover it again
[Music]
no I've never played chess at work in
the office back then when I had no no a
that wasn't allowed at all and not even
technically possible they I think they
blocked all of that stuff the only thing
that was was really possible back then
was to follow the Arts Tournament yeah
that did work here you could the the
chess news sites that that was working
so I ultimately blunder da pawn which is
great but let's see what happens i mean
you seized in some kind of pin here
Queen will probably move though so it
doesn't really matter all that much
yeah I'm ideas f form and check made
almost so yeah this is a move actually
expected he's completely he never cares
much about to TG consideration sir so
I'm grabbing this and now FYE probably
goes Queen B 7 i'm sure if i can allow
that and i want to cover this so that i
can recapture with the peace
yeah many openings are playable and Anna
normal level let's say that is not
played on the very top level with
instructional content returned to my
channel at some point and I assume I
don't know to be honest it's it's very
difficult because it's a it's a matter
of how much time as I have and it's it's
really taking lots of time to produce
decent instructional content and
currently I don't have that time I mean
I'm just absolutely busy with with doing
other things so do I get some counter
plane
a pond is definitely quick attack Bishop
do for you three those kind of things
they also feel dangerous I expected him
to play Queen c6 and rugby seven at some
point but she never did maybe now but
now I will definitely consider to go to
f5 now I will definitely go to f5 if you
play screen no doesn't so this looks
normal 43
or that looks dangerous definitely
dangerous
yeah I should definitely do some other
things yes I'm perfectly aware of that
it's just I didn't quite get to it yeah
this looks dangerous for white really
dangerous how is he defending here
Queens is sex em okay Queenie at five
though comes with the tempo on the book
so what I am a hard time to believe you
can survive this so I can take now on f2
twice 95 immediately is also interesting
not completely convincing though let's
do this
yeah but now i can check chat window
rock or the bishop I think out tonight
resides yeah okay I'm happy with that
one I think that was a decently and a
decent d played game so let's get going
for for a new one at least one GM scalp
power per session is needed um yeah I
should do some should do some sports you
definitely right and i will i work i
will get to it i will definitely get to
it so who's on down let's see i would i
it's quite busy
[Music]
yeah I really don't know this can start
a position type is difficult so let's
play Jerome we get a Sicilian here I
don't know what you place I place that
one okay so we get down maroc see bind
yeah the zone this is a common line that
I had on the board quite a number of
times so yeah you can stop the a porn
like this let's see what he does usually
you put them on c1 and b1 quite sure
here though it's possible
yeah 95 or not Jim that's a typical
question I'm I'm going for that even
though I just recognize that I'm
weakening the default square in the
process not a good Queen trade why dont
they play the clothes sicilian at the
top level yeah because black cow gets a
good game with the Lord em every
reasonable response it just doesn't put
enough pressure it is not a bad line to
player on the club level because it is
fairly easy to learn but on the on the
very top it just is not doesn't have
enough bite not enough pressure that you
can put yeah I'm trying to go to an c6
here in this position I wonder ever
managed yeah probably not you will take
this now but that's not a position I
mind playing it looks so roughly equal
or maybe slightly better for me
interesting yeah I was intending this
anyway
[Music]
yet it's gained some space I could have
started with g4 hmm maybe that was
better yeah sure sometimes they play the
closest ID cards have won a quite nice
game there against runoffs love water
check you're right there's nothing wrong
with the opening it's just it's not
something that is very dangerous or to
play on a regular basis oh wow we get
those questions still when i'm going to
play Jerry yeah well he's always dodging
dodging any kind of challenge so it's a
it's useless and I think it is also no
point if he wants to play I'm happy but
he will never play any any strong
youtube so um let's see don't quite see
a way to make progress it's so
interesting I think candy I'd take even
his rook has no squares this is funny I
[Music]
wonder even look takes eruptive five is
kind of interesting from JC forward I
think doubling is stronger maybe you
hook d5 and then e five currently cannot
move the mahi ok he cannot move the
night and then he moves it but I can
take a form
check yeah I'm not going to play a
ginger GM in the nearest future because
of many other projects I simply have no
time in the new year that that seems
reasonable check
oh my god yeah you're really stiff still
has complete morons there with racist
comments oh my god I i cannot i cannot
sense that i don't have the ability
so yeah that was probably not and I can
just go away for him it's great for oh
that actually did irritate me that that
bloody [ __ ] them didn't didn't do this
well going to e7 or trying to go to
yourself so oh no that's not blunder if
I forgot about that bloody move that's
really terrible yeah it's a good comment
the black the black pieces probably
triggered him maybe at the camp on
ending is still win but 92 94 is still
slightly tricky
yeah you have crazy people on no matter
where you are I mean in the chest stream
or whatever it's really impossible to to
avoid it seems check check so let's see
now over to the Kings side check black
resigns
oh that's a cool had a quick question
what is them what will be the most plate
opening a top level in 2015 oh I have no
idea I have no idea I think we will see
many sidelines that currently I beg
waters plate yeah things like Knight f3
g3 be three those kind of leg openings i
think that are not so forced i don't i
don't really believe that we will have
school still has done in Berlin all the
time okay so big master we can I get a
banker in actually a way for hmm ok
there is a number of good replies this
is one of them nitey to wow the night is
normally completely misplaced on each
window banco because it has absolutely
no relation to the queenside especially
see form ok
a little bit mystified so he wants to
play for me that seems I don't feel that
this is very likely going to succeed
let's see to 94 now i also believe here
the English openings like that we will
probably see more often on the top level
by the way is not so I mean for normal
players that is not particularly
relevant what they do so why isn't that
working I don't get it when you go with
your rook
[Music]
yeah he loses material now rook to
Bishop takes III yeah the question is if
I want to do that Bishop takes Queen
takes Queen a to Quincy too yeah I think
I will there's no reason not to take the
material
so an exchange up better than nothing
yeah chronic am actually rarely one with
the villain he drew tons of games but I
think he only won against Greece shocked
when grogs folder drawn king and porn
ending in the London candidates 2013 but
chrome dev Kramnik of course played the
Berlin extremely effectively in his
match as you remember when that was on
the internet yeah the first game where
Kramnik played the villain and at the
time everybody thought okay this is just
a one-off yeah he places once and never
again and then he played it the whole
time and I came I'm also threatening
Ruby 3m a typical Benko gone wrong wyd
jazz center is crumbling Quincy tune I
don't want to retreat really well to
keep some pressure on
oh wow I didn't want to move that should
I wanted to play rugby for of course wow
that was not intended yeah okay come on
let's play that it was completely
unattended Jesus I wanted to cook before
okay whatever let's trade it this is by
far not ideal by far not ideal yeah I
want to jerk the phone and somehow I got
I got onto the square I don't know how
really yeah this is not good at all
Christ I really hate to lose against
this crap play I mean come on by a free
in my lip I have to play this this
nonsensical move now Jesus I place it
really bad really weird
can take a seven I should have just
played c2 probably immediately wow I
don't understand anything in this game
absolutely nothing I understand and now
I'm winning again probably maybe not it
was just a totally a try besides now
that was a completely wacky mouse lab
here yeah I wanted to play route before
in this position just to trade stuff now
then he has to this was what I wanted to
do and this should win somehow yeah but
somehow i went to play loop Druker look
back yeah weird okay like one more game
and then I call it a day at least some
some points up so what did i do here i
lost against paranoid and the dragon and
the Kirlian gamer okay yeah the banco is
really gained started quite successful
opening for me let's go Cara where that
worked fine sorry guys
I had exactly the same thing against
Yardbird recently
yeah no Carol come but we got a funky
rui lopez instead that's a that's a
really strange-looking line but it is
interesting Bishop f7 actually gets what
let's get strapped body I'm not just
blundering a piece here when I dash out
all that in 16 seconds I have some idea
so I wanted peace but this this these
are some pawns how to do this would like
to break this down quickly if possible
[Music]
I'm not so happy with giving them the H
file but i think i should try to put the
porn quickly on g form like this so that
i can use those squares here night air
force' I need am better developed champ
and I should use that I feel maybe I
should have played night f4 actually
[Music]
[Music]
not so easy night f-for yeah but I would
you see cover this now I mean I'm
threatening to take on f3 as well like
butchy wanna take f3 and the debt I felt
of 92 Teague's my night maybe it's not
coming back I them I should have thought
about that Jackie I have to I have to
know there's no way back knight takes
Bishop g4 is clearly good for me but if
he's not doing this it doesn't feel all
that clear
rookie seven maybe on how do i how do i
enter this i would like to enter his
position maybe just double yeah just
detect g3 yeah this is good actually he
has no clear way of covering this night
f1 i probably i don't know what i do
then but not if one doesn't really feel
dangerous
I don't really see a good move on and it
seems he also doesn't okay so taking 95
yes but this is night f seven and 96 our
checks but are they dangerous but I
cannot really think now for a long time
so save this I don't think that this is
very dangerous knight c6 King c7 should
be fine look t6 look t6 maybe actually
Oh what I have king is seven yeah okay
a threat the night h3y also
you
hmm lays out of moves it's really out of
moves there's a question the carrots
defense I go on variation yeah it is
that's quite solid that's an interesting
[Music]
that's an interesting of big line if you
can play one in six like you're ready
for the French one is six and Bishop
before check is very okay check average
at square you on b6 wait check I can do
this oh that's made of it to check it's
also made checkmate okay so finishing on
a high note with the win I hope you
enjoyed the stream it was fun yeah
having some regulars on like every week
and also some some new names yeah it was
fun for me again a couple of points even
though I played one or two bad games and
was lucky a little bit ok guys thanks
for watching I'll be back next week next
Monday bye bye